et bien pour le passage de la deuxième à
la troisième chaîne vous tourner le
bouton correspondant qui vous permettra
de retrouver l'un ou l'autre programme
de la deuxième ou de la troisième chaîne
je pense que tout ceci est bien clair
pour l'énorme majorité des appareils qui
reçoivent la seconde chaîne y en a
environ 8 millions le réglage de la
deuxième chaîne se fait comme sur un
poste radio et pour recevoir la
troisième chaîne
il vous suffira en partant de votre
position actuelle feinte 2 de monter à
la plage de 28
je vous rappelle que la plage 22 et la
plage 28 ouvrir en deuxième et troisième
chaîne mais que par contre vous avez
paris-sud villebon sur 62 et ne vous
communiquerons ultérieurement les autres
plages dans notre prochaine émission
mais il faut que vous compreniez bien
que sur ce type de téléviseur vous ne
passerez de la deuxième à la troisième
chaîne qu en déréglant la seconde chaîne
pour la régler à nouveau quand vous y
reviendrez
c'est pour éviter cet inconvénient que
depuis environ quatre ans les
constructeurs ont mis en vente un type
d'appareil plus perfectionnés dans
laquelle le cadran modèle poste radio et
remplacé est complété par des touches
présélectionnés pour chacune des 2e et
3e shell monsieur fait commente avec ce
type d'appareil plus récent procès de
temps sur cet appareil nous obtiendrons
la troisième chaîne simplement en
enclenchant une touche prévu à cet effet
lorsque la touche de la troisième chaîne
est en france et nous allons le dernier
accord petites aiguilles rouges qui se
trouve en haut à droite sur le canal 28
c tionale de la troisième chaîne et nous
seront réglés définitivement concernant
une fois pour toutes neuf portés dans
les modèles encore plus récents nous
avons une variante les touches sont des
contacts électriques qui permettent de
recevoir la première chaîne la deuxième
chaîne et bientôt la troisième chaîne
les réglages se faisant indépendamment
dans un tiroir
situé en haut
ou en bas de l'appareil suivant les
modèles quoi qu'il en soit hormis les
appareils qui sont équipés de touche
près réglable le passage de la deuxième
à la troisième chaîne sera une manoeuvre
délicate et nous vous conseillons de
vous adresser à votre installateur qui
vous expliquera suivant le modèle
d'appareil que vous possédez des
manoeuvres à faire pour recevoir la
troisième chaîne dans de bonnes
conditions
oui il s'agit là d'une recommandation
essentielle
le réglage de vaud récepteur pour les
passer de la 2d dans la troisième chaîne
est une chose délicate n'hésitez pas à
demander conseil à vos revendeurs aux
adieux aux électriciens qui sont là pour
vous assister
n'hésitez pas non plus si vous le
souhaitez à nous écrire émission micros
et caméras maison de l'eau et f à paris
nous nous efforcerons de vous répondre
[Musique]